bom dia a todos
é esta a minha fala hoje é um clube
sobre a informação
a informação como algo que é
completamente previsível nascerá atual e
que pode estar muito para além daquilo
que nós imaginamos todos nós hoje em dia
vemos a informação por trovoadas um dos
nossos telemóveis nos nossos
computadores
o sistema estiver físicos ano à nossa
volta usam informação para processar
para alterar o seu comportamento uma
forma completamente familiar a todos
todos nós nos quais consideramos como
transparentes como fazendo parte parte a
parte da nossa vida
mas a verdade é que é o grande problema
da informação vem do facto de poder ser
usado em competições como é que as
competições usam informação
nós podemos ver quem fuma são
basicamente existem três naturezas
aquela formação clássica é chamada de
shannon execute tensões a informação
presente extensões de coisas são
diferentes
a informação que hoje funcionam levados
por exemplo dizer que algo que tem uma
certa coisa só tem uma certa propriedade
ou aquilo que é mais importante chamar
uma informação pode ser pela forma de
uma prescrição pode ser um conjunto de
instruções e aí é que está o facto de
ver a informação que o poder da
computação vai se livrar combinarmos
estes três tipos de informação de uma
forma completamente uniforme comunicando
a vários níveis como os outros
eu vou dar apenas um pequeno exemplo
estarmos com um final muito santo na
competição que é o facto de através do
software nós podemos construir mundos
virtuais hotel evito ir lá ver com o
software tudo é possível construir é uma
coisa completamente nova que só por seu
de informática que vamos dar um exemplo
é o computador macintosh foi foi
inventado em nosso declínio em 84 pelos
três jogos e em um espectro de santa que
foi o primeiro computador para ter esse
tipo de interface gráfica através
daquelas
o time teve daniel espanha será total
a primeira fase dos anos não é é é é um
pequeno exemplo aqui esta primeira
impressão michael foi uma primeira
aplicação construída que permite de
facto você quais mais do que na altura
quando avistou primeira vez com o samu
pelo lápis é possível fazemos no
maracanã
enfim é provável que isso possa cabo
verde a relevar não é uma entorse
funcionário é uma simulação do macintosh
que está a correr dentro daquela janela
dentro do meu conteúdo pessoal neste
momento é isto é possível porque porque
existe uma linguagem de programação
neste caso até seus avós inscritos e
social e vão falar que está a correr
dentro do nosso brasil internet
todos os nossos idosos internet sabem
conquistar aquela linguagem o vaivém
teve aquela b por lina com deixando
escrever um programa que vai simular um
apple macintosh em 1984 até o mais
pequeno detalhe toda maneira que todo
software que existia na altura por
governo macintosh em 1984 palavra correr
vento dentro daquela dentro do meu
computador e até posteriormente essas
cópias deus deve ter é que nós
concluímos consegui construir mundos
virtuais por cima uns dos outros numa
espécie de hierarquia e iluminados
alternativas cada uma delas oculta para
a seguinte
mas que na prática funcionam todos em
conjunto é um facto é um de tudo um dos
aspectos mais planos da computação e
informática
aquela linguagem de programação onde
está a escrita o aqui ou aqui é o
simulador daquela macintosh sua vez está
inscrito numa outra linguagem técnica
semana java sua vez é executada numa
máquina virtual virtual filho daquela
máquina está construído em área do euro
em software numa máquina física não uma
máquina eletrônica mas quer faca máquina
em koff também cortou no software
escrito em java no mundo inteiro por sua
vez está escrita no modo a linguagem do
mês ao que aquela imagem que ela estava
em um conjunto de condições mais
próximas do mar
um pessoa física guardou é que por sua
vez pode ser traduziu para um professor
que finalmente aquilo que nós compramos
na porta do hotel para colocar nossa
categoria 5 é feito com material físico
mas que por sua vez internamente também
pode ser programado relevar nós
quisermos podemos alterar o conjunto de
edições do psone hotel para fazer o
simulado outra pessoa qualquer
instintivamente sucessivamente até o
ponto em que hoje em dia é possível
simular mas grandes infra-estruturas do
tipo níveis na cloud é coleções inteiras
que cometeu nos completamente virtuais
dinamicamente só como posso imaginar se
não que o filme matrix é possível criar
ruas alterar a estrutura física do
espaço colocar pessoas não estavam nós
podemos imaginar que é no hand no embate
senta todos os conteúdos costa não são
os conteúdos físicos que nós vemos meus
carros infiniti mas são computadores
completamente virtuais que são criados
instantaneamente dinamicamente consoante
os políticos vêm através da rio santos o
computador os comportamentos simulados
para o ponto de vista nutricional está a
utilizar o destaque pelo seu software só
com pessoas completamente diferentes
não é preciso for software não conseguia
distinguir estava a correr numa máquina
real está ocorrendo uma máquina virtual
sua vez também estaria simulasse
estimulada por cima votar máquina
virtual e assim sucessivamente
tanto isto é esta realidade de
virtualização da vmware gnt o econômico
fundo final é oprimido hoje em dia as
empresas localizar em grande parte do
seu avô a pasta de infraestrutura e
valesca um princípio faz uma coisa quase
imagem que não foi desta que é
conquistando realidades virtuais
virtuais próximas umas das outras que
parecem não ligar via para todos nós
como sendo máquinas físicas como outras
quaisquer processos existentes
informática como em toda a natureza em
geral e agora eu gostava de entrar no
modo aquilo que ele mais perto do tempo
para mostrar algumas amigas
as nossas áreas da natureza não deve
trazer aqui as máquinas virtuais também
também acontece a primeira máquina
vitória enfrentada pela casa até foi
esta máquina curiosamente consumida pelo
valor em turim
vocês devem circular um filme que agora
é é bastante sucesso organização não
entregamos a primeira pessoa que
imaginou que as máquinas poderiam pensar
eu também conseguiu este novo muito
simples o que é ser humano computador
universal
o computador do ensino a qualquer outro
computador é curiosamente esta máquina
construída para um universo controla por
uma fita é muito precisa como uma célula
a célula posso imaginar o venia
encontrarem o programa que se ela vai
escutar duas motos e as ela contou no
conjunto na cadeirinha permita executar
esse programa
tanto o dna pode ser visto como uma
modificação informação representa o
código genético organismo mas não só com
a linknet entanto o time está agendado
velha é tudo um conjunto de informação
que o que estava em causa a inflamação
conjunto de instruções que permite
enviar é toda a formação no rio de
célula desde está mais elementar
eventualmente até o desenvolvimento do
organismo
como todos vocês pensaram que tal em
tese a criança informação campanha
antecipar nada com a selecção que os
portes físicos está atrás do que o
sistema não antecipar nada venia é
fumado quatro núcleos todos nós
conhecemos tanto os quatro pilotos
conseguiu ver quem quer que governe até
em quatro núcleos contigo eu tentei mas
será que vão processar a crise está
arrumando algum golpe consoante psi phi
don don conceito de design prático a que
impõe a conveniar 34 no pior que
prometeu esta funcionária da mesma o que
está em causa não é ser enquadradas 13 a
informação que o site contém e quando
nós observamos toda toda esta hierarquia
máquinas virtuais vendas elas vão desde
a leitura do venia
uma transcrição e posterior é é a
utilização pelo rio a soma para
construir proteínas que por sua vez vão
constituir de patos fundamentais do
organismo
estamos basicamente a presença do maior
arquivo máquinas virtuais tóquio - a
perna no mundo da computação permitem
construir um sistema extremamente
complexa pois não se trata de
procedimentos simples de informação
então vai completar não se pode ser
feito é o seguinte o próprio rio a soma
que aquele organismo uma célula que
permita identificar o o osx é genética
para produzir as proteínas
eu próprio é construído exatamente a
mesma forma como as proteínas que
constrói são construídas tanto
exatamente um sucesso está completamente
certo sobre uma estrutura causal de
informação é um aspecto interessante
nesta festa no dia é possível o gene a
alterar o código genético de uma célula
amanhã é é fazer com que ela faça o
julgamento do re maior possa fazer você
se programar o comportamento marcel
suter exemplo o projeto 800 marketing
onde é possível escrever um programa
numa linguagem semana velho rock pra
casa uma linguagem também usava 805
desintegrados você que na prática
natural traduzida como pilotava uma
seqüência a velha que permita alterar o
comportamento do céu e fazê lo no fundo
é escutar um comportamento completamente
diferente porque o papel estava
desenhada inicial mesmo minha segunda
luzia tem a ver com o novo termine mesmo
que parece da computação todos todos nós
temos como lei geral é nos permite mas
alega que todas as teorias físicas do
mundo mesmo que ela e quântica é tenista
que o sistema inclui um livro último
forma completamente previsível na
informática é necessário configurar um
crime mesmo porque todo o tempo com
mutações que existem por exemplo um
sistema de tv e morrer e na ordem
diferente as mensagens se torna a
história não
em entrevista agora podemos imaginar o
seguinte todos os véus do pib de
computação que tentam capturar um
determinismo fazendo reduzindo o nutri
mesmo os sistemas que dentro mas muitos
paralelos
nós nem formato é sempre assim fizemos
até que nós que fazemos a nós já temos
muitos paralelos multiverso se quiser é
uma realidade com a qual nós temos que
levar quando estudamos os guris tivemos
nos sistemas informáticos
atualmente o multiverso oxi levarmos
para wells é estruturada de forma
rotineira por exemplo - a computação
quântica núcleo de computação quântica
usou o facto de uma parte por toy
aumentar tudo estar em mais do que um
estado ao mesmo tempo podemos imaginar
que ela estava perdendo ela pode estar
numa mistura de vários estados em
universos paralelos que as panelas
existem mesmo relato muito surpresa os
computadores quando eles podem ser
construídos e nós ficamos na prática que
eu só podem funcionar porque estão a ser
feitas com pretensões a processamento de
informação se quiser
ao mesmo tempo e universo para laos onde
se pode ser explorado por exemplo uma
aplicação tão simples como estamos aqui
e que o objeto do do nosso sistema é por
exemplo ensinar qual é que é o cartão de
visita correto é uma competição especial
terá que passar todos os cartões em
seqüência o mesmo grito implementar num
contentor planta pode simultaneamente
cruzar todos pertencem ao mesmo tempo e
selecionar aquilo que interessa é uma
forma completamente instantânea
é uma coisa maravilhosa temos tentado
tirar partido do facto de se terem de
facto vários universos coronel
o último exemplo mesmo que termina já
completamente entendem os limites da
especulação mas não pra primeiro te ver
cowell
seguinte de ver como é muito
interessante conhecida como o terceiro
lugar ficou o fundo da minha vivência de
que a informação pode ter na estrutura
do universo um papel muito mais
fundamental do que tanto nós pensamos
nesta este princípio é o seguinte texto
a gente conhece mais ou menos agora
estão que ninguém gosta muito organizado
e vai por aqui negros black estão por
toda a parte
foi basicamente um buraco comigo é um
sítio do espaço onde a força da
gravidade é tão forte que nada consegue
separar a primeira atração do proac e
nem sequer é bom ter um debate ao longo
de várias décadas entre o óculo foi
fundador da teoria do latim - conhecida
como guerra buracos negros conseguinte
um buraco negro é igual tudo cai dentro
de seu bom mas a verdade é que existe um
princípio um tanque na natureza que não
só leva à conservação do avasin não
existe um princípio possível ver com a
informação da natureza é a informação no
spot tudo isso até criava pode ser
destruída
tanto é que um problema é o seguinte
quando o objeto de repente cai dentro de
um buraco negro o mec também que essa
informação vai e o outro ó quem dizia
que a inflamação dias por exemplo acesso
à energia não era proibida
com essa cabeça em um buraco negro faz
com que ele fique cada vez maior de
informações por dia
é bom ter esse gasto batem continuam no
mac mini no ano existe consenso
atualmente diz que toda a informação dos
objetos caem dentro do bloco negro fica
está lá
por isso o horizonte do vaqueiro sob a
forma de uma qualificação de tudo o que
está vendo o buraco negro está uma coisa
santo por críticos estão exatamente que
experimentalmente que toda massa
acalento buraco negro aumenta e não num
buraco negro da superfície tanto
significa que tudo o que está havendo
falar comigo realidade está classificado
como um holograma na superfície do
buraco negro existe hoje em dia uma
trilha que o esquema é levar o universo
tal como conhecemos é é como pode ser
visto como interior de um buraco negro
gigantesco é que toda tudo a informação
do que se passa dentro do universo
ataque ficava nessa esfera gigantesca
drogas utilize esta época tempo foi
publicações têm no max planck institute
of physics
na manhã este tema de investigação atual
tentamos africanas concretas
existem dezenas de acidentes sobre isto
e há uma ligação fortíssima entre a
informação ea estrutura da natureza da
questão que se coloca é o seguinte
quando nós às vezes pensamos estão
comentários ao final do pt
nós pensamos sobre o que é a estrutura
do mundo à nossa volta é facto é
relevado no pt é real eo que é virtual
quando temos todos estes exemplos com
estas e arquias de victor lados
relevados curte umas das outras e quando
quanto e quando os cantores construímos
o mundo ao contrário se quiserem física
tocam nós conhecemos essa história
também que o irmão é riso é foi atos
pois usar com são feitas de católicas
prover são feitas de partículas
subatômicas sua versão foi de partículas
subatômicas eventualmente córneas coisas
estranhas constante matemáticos em
última análise apenas de informação
obrigado pela atenção
a palestra eu tenho uma pergunta volante
stefan tomkim isto a gente se lembra que
stepanov previa um problema para a
humanidade viva a inteligência
artificial qual é a opinião
será que estamos ameaçados pelos robôs
ainda estamos muito longe disso com as
tracks
uma vez aí irá acontecer eu acho que
vamos ter possivelmente a mensagem dos
gols mas a um ritmo tão lento lento que
eu não provar que dizemos sempre próxima
etapa
[Aplausos]